hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
february 22nd what's going on
how are you how's it going
how was your week um
are you having a good one ah that's good
everybody back east and in the midwest
and out in texas
everybody out in texas got their [ __ ]
horses frozen is that what happened
jesus christ texas is hilarious man i
love that they have their own grit
i know that it didn't work out you know
what i mean but i like what they're
doing out there
you know i guess there's the east coast
grid the west coast grid and the texas
grid they were just like [ __ ] you
we're having our own electricity all
right you know and like most people
when when they're working it out you
know there's gonna be a little bugs
but you wait you wait some day you wait
some day when some terrorist
comes over here and pisses on some
[ __ ] uh
transformer out in the east coast and
nobody has power right and another one
does it out in the west and they think
they got the whole [ __ ] country but
texas will still be up and running
there pops ain't froze over they're
still gonna be up and running
and that's gonna be it and they're gonna
have a two-pronged attack
you send half your crazy [ __ ] texans
with their ar-15s and their [ __ ]
cattle prodders to the east and the
other half out to the west and they'll
[ __ ] settle it
right then all the liberal larry's on
the coast
are gonna have to sit there and be like
you know what okay
so like yeah i mean i guess
ar-15s and cattle prods can work in
certain situations but i just want to
say for me
that when that guy peed on the
transformer
i was in the middle of a botox meeting
um
anyway shout out to anybody in [ __ ]
i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna shout
i'm just a shout out right now to the
real men
the real men and women in texas right
now who can actually listen to this
because there's a lot of people that go
to texas right they go out there they
buy a pickup truck and some cowboy boots
they start walking the walk right
listening to country music
little [ __ ] dip between the cheek and
gum right
they're not about it they know how to
round up some [ __ ] rattlesnakes split
it down it's barely
cooked that [ __ ] um if you're
listening right now when you're in texas
you were smart enough to get a backup
generator
you know i'm not talking to the people
sitting in a car right now with [ __ ]
earmuffs on you know with their car
plugged in you know charging off their
car i'm not talking about that [ __ ] i'm
not talking about you people i'm talking
about
i'm talking about the real texans who
can trace their bloodlines back to sam
houston
um anyways i'm just [ __ ] around
that's a [ __ ] situation
out there so hopefully uh you know
actually well someday they're gonna look
back on it probably someday soon i would
say
would be july they're gonna look back
remember when it was freezing out
you know as opposed to having your balls
melting into your thigh
yeah texas crazy weather in texas
reptiles and everything it's not for the
faint of heart
um and i love that state that's my last
tour last place
i i toured in dallas austin and houston
and i had a great [ __ ] time college
football's big out there
so i hope your pipes get unfrozen soon
all right
um old freckles got some energy this
week i did some shows i'm recording this
thing right before the bruins versus the
[ __ ]
flyers in lake tahoe
i wonder if michael corleone's gonna go
there i don't like you people out here
with your greasy hair and your oily skin
um godfather too isn't that where they
were at lake tahoe
lake tahoe um you know i was thinking
you know with all this crazy weather
global warming and all of that [ __ ] you
know someday when i get older
you know if i live long enough to have
grandkids i figured i gotta live to be
like 90 for that you know
um i'll i'll say [ __ ] like not 90.
if i can make it into my uh 80s i think
i can do it
and i'll be like yeah i remember when i
was a kid they could you could play
hockey outside
it'd get so cold the water would freeze
what does frozen water look like grandpa
you wouldn't believe it if i told you
and and you could stand on it you could
skate on it
cross-check your friend in the teeth and
say i'm sorry i didn't see you
then that point some [ __ ] robot will
come in
bringing some [ __ ] liquid food
really built in the future is the robot
still going to be like
in my world it is [ __ ] you guys you
don't you know
do you really come on this podcast for
the production value
all right no green screens here man
just pure uncut ignorance let's plow
ahead
um bruins lost to the devils the other
night devil's strong team as always you
know they got lindy rough
behind the bench as joe bartnick says
from the great puck off podcast you get
lindy rough
immediately turns the teams around
you're gonna get an extra 15 20
wins a year okay the man knows how to
[ __ ] get a team together
so uh yeah they dominated the first two
periods then as always bruins
best third period team in the nhl at
least in the from what i've seen and
i've only watched the bruins so i'm
sticking with it
um i think it was two nothing then they
came back
and we made it two to one i believe i
think we lost two to one or was it three
to two i don't remember it was a few
days ago
and uh i kind of was coming home late
night to watch
the games um celtics beat up the [ __ ]
hawks
that was nice took that one early 33 or
32 points in the first two quarters
i was liking that i think we play them
again maybe tonight i'm not sure
but i just tape all the [ __ ] and then
after everybody goes to bed i just
i go through the game having a great
[ __ ] time so
um speaking of a great time
um i did some shows last week because i
was getting ready i was gonna do a
benefit online
and uh i did some shows out in venice i
got to run my hour
and uh had such a [ __ ] good time i'm
really
it was just amazing you know what i mean
to have people there you know they had
masks on and [ __ ] and they were all
[ __ ] spread i was hilarious they were
like on the other side of a pool
and then there was like people up high
and
but you know yeah i'm just sort of used
to what that sounds like now so now i
can kind of get on like a roll
you know whereas before just the whole
thing just sounded like bombing so i
would be questioning myself while the
crowd's like no we're having a good time
just
there's just not a lot of us so um
gathering i'm let's not let's let's
let's dial it back here it's not a crowd
i did some stand-up for a gathering of
people
um out in venice and i did uh i did two
shows
i didn't oh i did one show wednesday no
one thursday and one friday
and uh it felt [ __ ] great you know
the first night i just did it and then i
left
cruised home because i had to put my
daughter to bed
and the second she went to bed you know
she goes to bed around seven and the uh
show was at eight i jumped in my car
cruised out there
literally walked in poured a cup of tea
my throat coatee
drank a little bit because i'm not good
at writing jokes so i have to scream the
f word really loudly to get the laughs
uh went on stage did my [ __ ]
said thank you i'll see you guys
tomorrow night jumped in my car went
home and i was home by like [ __ ]
like 9 30. cruised out came right back
it was great right
so the next night
my lovely wife came with me and i can't
remember the last time i took her to a
show right
she came out and then that night we
ended up hanging out a little bit
and um i gotta tell you my wife oh my
god she looked gorgeous
she looked gorgeous she's uh she's back
at it man she's always pretty but you
know i mean now she's been like
all right okay we're on the other side
of two kids
you know she's been eating great working
out just absolutely crushing it and she
had a new coat on and looked
[ __ ] stunning and i told her how good
she looked the whole [ __ ] way home
um it was great you know then we stopped
off at a little taco truck
you know felt bad like i was [ __ ] up
for diet but the next day she's like no
i ate i eat it this time and i'm not
eating i wait 12 hours and i'm going
she's just [ __ ] on it
like she took our kid out with some
other kids and they got ice cream she
didn't get the ice cream so today when i
took my kid you know doing the balance
bike thing
that's that's that's the daddy-daughter
date we go to the park we go around on
the balance bike she tries to run over
my toes
laughing her ass off not realizing she's
learning how to ride a bike i've never
been more wrong about the bounce bike
the bounce bike is the [ __ ]
all you old dads out there with your
[ __ ] training wheels just throw them
out the window it's stupid
it doesn't work right um although i
think you're supposed to they finally
figured out you're supposed to
have them be a little higher than the
tire not just on the ground
so they're sort of like sort of
teetering that now that makes more sense
that's more of a balance bike i would
think so
um if you are going to put on training
wheels i would recommend that the
training wheels are like an inch higher
maybe
than the uh the back tire and then i
think it could work but anyway i am
totally sold on that and i've been
having a great time with it
so my wife has been inspiring me because
i put on like [ __ ] 10 pounds and i'm
like all right
if you're doing this i'll be doing it
too so i'm very proud of her
and uh like i said she looks amazing um
which is pretty awesome
you know pretty awesome to have a
[ __ ] beautiful wife i got to be
honest with you
even though uh i'm a [ __ ] pain in the
ass i still lucked out there so anyway
plowing ahead here um so i was taking my
daughter over
to go to uh
to go to the [ __ ] park right and i
don't know man i just been in a mood
you know i thought i got on the other
side of this [ __ ] i thought okay all i
gotta do is if i have issues with people
i just sort of talked to him about it
and everything was good but then you
know what i find i i figured out
something else that gets my anger going
is i try to do too much [ __ ] in a day i
always have like 15
[ __ ] things i'm gonna do and then i'm
running out of time and i try and rush
through [ __ ]
and it puts me in a shitty mood so i'm
driving down the street
right i'm getting close to the park
we're on the side street and there's one
of these [ __ ] bicycle [ __ ] who's
just way out in the road there's no
[ __ ] reason to be
that far out in the road you know he was
like literally like
like 20 feet away from the curb he's in
the middle of the road
so i'm like you [ __ ] douche right so
i [ __ ] wow and i went around him
right
and i stopped at a stop sign then you
know what he did he rode to the left
side of my car blew through the stop
sign and went
and kept going right and i felt this
[ __ ] twinge of anger
in me um
that i kind of forgot that my kid was in
the car
and i was actually thinking like
am i gonna i'm not gonna fight this guy
like i'm not i'm not fighting this guy
i'm [ __ ] 52 years old bad shoulders
uh i drove up alongside him and i was
like well and then
i quickly went back down like i get my
kids here i can't say anything i just
drove by and he looked at me waiting for
me to say something i just pointed at my
brain like you know
whatever you know smart guy right you
dumb [ __ ]
trying to prove a point so you pass me
on the left and you blow through a stop
sign
if my daughter wasn't there because he
was a little chunky what i would have
said was
if you keep doing that your bicycle's
just gonna be as frosted as the donuts
you've been eating you fat
[ __ ] but you know what when your kid is
there
you can't say those things you just
gotta you know
i don't know what
i don't know but it was [ __ ] funny
and i actually got to tip my cap to him
because
he was right because i was impatient and
we were coming up to a stop sign anyway
it's just like people on bikes kind of
trigger my [ __ ]
anger and other [ __ ] it has nothing to
do with them okay
the guy's trying to get in shape god
bless him it's a nice
[ __ ] sunday afternoon and then some
bald orange douche comes over impatient
because he's got too much [ __ ] going on
like i was literally in the car
with my daughter talking to her while
also listening to a french lesson and
she's going daddy you're not listening
you're not listening to me daddy you're
not listening to me and that was just
like
what am i doing you know when i learned
from my drum lesson
that you know if you're [ __ ]
practicing drums in front of the tv
you're doing both of those terribly not
as well
you're not focusing on the tv 100 and
you're not playing drums 100 so both of
them are like toned down so i was just
like
what am i doing this is the
daddy-daughter date so i turned off the
french
and and then all of a sudden we were
having great conversations
she was telling me all about the kids at
school
she always tells me like you know
so-and-so was talking during the nap
and this person's really fast when they
run and this person does this and this
person does that like just tells like
the whole thing
tells me you know you know i can always
tell the boy she likes because she talks
about them more than she talks about the
others the whole thing is so damn
cute um and i'm really enjoying her
school that she goes to
and uh and then my son
i don't my son put it this way this kid
likes the ladies
all right he likes his dad but i'm
telling you if there's a female in the
room he's looking at her
and then reaching over like why don't
you hold me
instead of this uh whatever this [ __ ]
i don't know orange snowman here so
but i've been having a great time
hanging out with the kids
okay so look at me listen classic brain
all over the [ __ ] place because i got
000 [ __ ] things going i got 9 000
things i'm trying to talk to you about
bill just pick one [ __ ] thing and
talk about it
all right look i just got mad at myself
um so anywho
i was uh so my apologies to the guy on
the bike
uh i'm gonna try to do better with that
[ __ ] um
yeah i have to do better with that [ __ ]
i really do i got to like i've been i've
been really good about it
especially because i say on my podcast
that
these [ __ ] guys annoy the [ __ ] out of
me god forbid i ever hit one of them and
it's gonna be like
hey it was building up if you listen to
his podcast look at can i'd like to
submit
the podcast from february 22nd
2020. i don't know why it's a southern
lawyer but you always feel like if
you're getting railroaded right there's
always a southern lawyer there at least
that's how hollywood does it
you know that's how they [ __ ] do it
another thing that they do is that
whenever
there's a movie about racist white
people i used to do a bit about this
they always have to have the one
like whatever year the movie came out in
2007 there's always one white person
that is 2007
woke right or 20 20 20 21 or whatever
you know so then like you got it so then
you can get all the white people saying
all the racist stuff and then you got
the one
the one [ __ ] like hey man like i
don't think i agree with these are human
beings man
and that character exists for one
[ __ ] reason
and one reason only it's so white people
can sit in the theater
and lie to themselves that in 1938
that's the white person they would have
been
so then they can separate themselves
from these other white people right it's
like now i see like female
comics calling other white women karen's
in the crowd because they're separating
themselves
to be like i'm aware of this term and
i'm obviously not dead if i call
somebody else
it it this is what always happened which
is what i enjoyed
so much about this movie that i just saw
over the weekend uh
judas and the black messiah what i loved
about jesse plemmon's character is they
didn't do that with him
they made him you know a nice he
was medium [ __ ] up he wasn't as [ __ ]
up as the people above him
but he was he he protected what was his
and in the end because of the
organization he was working with his
character
was a piece of [ __ ] i mean i'm sort of
oversimplifying it but that's what i
loved about that movie forget about the
movie itself my god
um if you guys haven't seen it um
was uh make sure i say all these names
right daniel
um lakeith stanfield and and
my favorite in the movie can't i don't
play favorites here but uh as far as new
faces because there's other people i'm
obviously familiar with jesse on uh
breaking bad fargo and all of those
things la keith
on atlanta he's always amazing that guy
is
really interesting choices and uh
daniel kaluya from uh get out
and that other movie i i forget the name
of it i saw it with neo where they were
he was part of this uh
couple that were on the run from the
cops um
anyways but i'd never seen this actor
dominique fishbach she was [ __ ]
amazing amazing and uh unreal story and
i kind of was like going is it was it
really like
you know because any time hollywood
makes a movie you gotta be like okay
they're definitely leaning left here and
i kind of looked it up and yeah they
soda all checked out i don't want to
ruin the movie but
i do find it interesting
how they can go back 20 years
with tweets almost at this point and as
a comedian you can get
cancelled but if you go back 50 years in
the fbi and you see that they may or may
not have just
straight up murdered an innocent man
um there's no investigation there's no
cancel them it's like they always
whenever [ __ ] gets declassified
it's like everybody's dead but it's like
yes but the organization still exists
you know i can't sit there and be like
well that was 15 years ago i don't do
that joke anymore so
you know uh if you brought it up while i
was doing it then i think you had a case
but now
i guess cause i'm the same person and
i'm the person that said it i don't know
i always find that weird too about like
the catholic church how they were able
to kind of shake off
you know all of their uh jesus christ
all the [ __ ] that they were doing
um yeah so
anyway so i figured out a little bit
more about my anger and i am continuing
to work on it
and uh i have sucked at it
for like the last eight days i just
totally went back to being the same
douche i always was and uh so i got to
try to figure out i'm like well i don't
really have any
[ __ ] i need to squash with anybody
so what's going on the only thing i
could think of is i i was just trying to
do too many things so i have to do
something that i'm not good at
which is taking my foot off the gas
and sort of just being present
as opposed to working towards something
and i kind of learned during the
pandemic here that the reason i do that
is
it kind of keeps the the smoke
off me because if i slow down then all
the [ __ ] from my past catches up
with me
that i haven't dealt with
[Laughter]
so um yeah that is that is the deal
um let me do um
oh and i also [ __ ] figured out where
that leak was coming on my truck
i have uh a little power steering leak
in the steering assembly
so i have to go i got to text somebody a
buddy of mine who bought an old truck
and his buddy's going to buy an old
truck we all have like old fords
um he got like an f250 either he got the
the camper special the ranger or there
was one other model i forget what the
hell it was called
back then in the late 60s and uh
i absolutely love them dude i [ __ ]
old trucks are the goddamn best
they really are so um
you know i'm always paranoid about my
truck i don't want to get stolen
actually for some reason when i was
working out today old man workout by the
way i
i work out with bands now i've given off
on ever doing like a pull-up again
which is probably why i will be able to
because i'm just gonna start working out
with bands
doing yoga just admitting that i'm
[ __ ]
rapidly approaching my mid-50s gonna be
53 this year
and i have to just i can't be working
out like the same way i worked out when
i was in my teens in my 20s doing those
same [ __ ] things um so
you know it is what it is it is what it
is god damn it
um i don't know
it does bum me up i wish i had [ __ ]
the shoulders i had when i was a kid
like it's what was better than just
[ __ ]
seeing how much he could bench basically
the exact [ __ ] reason why
i uh blew out my shoulders to begin with
but anyway you live and you [ __ ]
learned i'm gonna be
uh
i'm gonna be i think i really enjoyed
doing that that i didn't really talk
about it when i did the benefit after i
did the two shows
in venice i then did the benefit show
and i went out into the valley
in this comedian's house and
um i always feel weird saying
everybody's names and [ __ ] so i don't
know
you know because i don't know if you
guys know if i said his name you'd
figure out where he lives and then if i
have a show there again i got some
psycho [ __ ] pulling up so
anyway it was a comedian's house and um
what was i gonna say the uh
you just went in where the garage was
and you know like those projector tv
things you can get
for people who want to watch tv outside
um
he had like three screens and then on
this on the screen were all of these
people that you know it's probably like
20 people per screen so you could look
at 60
people you could hear him laughing in
real time
the guy who hosted the show daniel
something or other i didn't get his last
name we kind of met
briefly at the beginning of the show he
was great he was hilarious it was all
the way over in australia
hosting the show it was 1 p.m the next
day over there
and uh dean del rey opened up and we
just had a great [ __ ] time
and that gave me um
it gave me some ideas man for live
podcasting and [ __ ] like that
um but what was cool is if it was if you
like said the name of the person up on
the board and if you gave him
three seconds they could then put him up
there and you could be like talking to
him and then the whole crowd
could see the person you were talking
about so
at one point i was looking at one of the
little squares and this person had a
bulldog and the bulldog was the only
thing sitting there and it was like
asleep
and uh it was funny i would just make
fun of a few things
you know what was funny was watching
people realize that they were being
watched was hilarious
that would be whatever be like hey joe
blow you know you get your feet up on
the ottoman there you know with your
orange shirt on can you [ __ ] blob and
all of a sudden the guy would like pop
up
started like waving and [ __ ] it was
really a lot of fun
and you know a couple of my reps
actually
watched the show and were like dude that
felt like a real show it felt you know
looked good
it was funny i felt like i was you know
watching a normally product uh produce
things so i don't know as they gradually
do this vaccine here uh i mean i don't
know
i mean at some point i got to start
making money because last year's the
first year i lost money
um i was just talking to somebody it's
the first time i lost money since i was
like 27
you know i didn't make a lot of money
but i always you know i was always
frugal so
but last year i legit like lost money so
i'm just like all right that's
if this is how it's gonna be i guess i
gotta just start
being captain kirk here stand-up comic
i'll just [ __ ] do that [ __ ] and when
it gets warm again
i'm gonna do socially distant shows or
whatever i'll i'll definitely figure it
out but i really want to thank everybody
that came out to the shows
and also the people that came out to the
benefit we were able to uh
it was a thousand people 10 bucks ahead
so it was 10 grand
that went to the uh aj quite a um
what do they call it startup fundraise
uh i always forget what they call those
things
um so we're going to put up a link here
if you guys want to donate some more
money last i checked the nhl cam nealy
and the bruins had raised like over 800
so it's such a great thing um
you know people coming together to try
and help this kid out help his family
out so they don't have to worry about
money or any of that [ __ ] they can just
get that kid
you know back to being healthy um so
yeah so thank you to everybody who uh i
i can't say came out turned on you you
know bought a ticket and
sat in your living room it was also cool
like watching people eating and stuff
like uh you know people like really made
it like an
evening like i saw a couple of couples
there and they were like
like throwing down like they really had
like a whole meal going and they were
laughing and having a good time
i saw another guy like when they didn't
know we were watching the crowd this guy
was like grinding up some weed
there was another guy smoking a cigar he
was another older dude sitting in front
of this white drum kit man it was really
[ __ ] cool
so uh it was it was yeah i couldn't i
mean i knew i was gonna have a good time
and i was like
as always before i go up it's like i'm i
just go home i'm gonna [ __ ]
i'm going off i gotta give these people
their [ __ ] money's worth and i ended
up doing like a little bit more time but
when i got up there it just was weird a
little bit
because somebody had their microphone
turned up a little too loud so i could
only hear their laugh but i was just
like
all right just block that out keep going
and then they sort of were able to
adjust that down and it was uh
it's an amazing experience so once again
thank you everybody all right let's do a
little bit of uh
let's do the ad reads here okay if you
haven't left yet just listen to me read
out loud and you're gonna get your
[ __ ] laughs for the week
okay look who it oh look who it is
me undies me undies look at the fbi
doo doo doo me undies me undies shooting
a [ __ ] innocent guy
how come you don't get [ __ ] cancelled
but if i tell a caitlyn jenner joke
ah i get a bunch of [ __ ] i don't know
that fills up my my
undies with some [ __ ] skid marks
and then i got to make an apology video
a couple of years later
all right all right me undies everybody
you know it's time we stopped messing
around about
funny things and talked about something
really serious and
important your underwear
that's right we're doing it me undies
believes undies are something that
should be yelled about
from the rooftops or shown off in the
mirror selfies for instagram they're not
undies they're not andi shy so let's
talk
who's not andi shy me undies isn't just
here to make sure
everybody is comfortable they're also
but they're all white meundies isn't
just here to make sure everybody is
comfortable
but they're also limiting the amount of
laundry you have
i feel like something got edited out
there i don't give a [ __ ] how thoughtful
they designed a membership that not only
saves you 30
on each order but delivers a fun new
pair of undies or socks right to your
door each month
plus you're the boss you can control
your shipments and you also get access
to
their most exclusive prints different
sizes slash styles
me undies are offered in a range of
sizes including extra small
to 4xl now that everyone is wfh
whatever the [ __ ] that means uh they
also offer the softest
loungewear fill your closet with things
you actually want to put on i want to
get some of that loungewear
i want to sit around and watch somebody
do a virtual show it looks fun as hell
make a little meal sit down with my
lovely wife all right me undies has a
great offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping myani's also has
their problem free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats no questions
exchange it gross to get 15 off your
first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee
go to meundies.com that's meundies.com
b-u-r-r
oh look who it is everybody old zip
businesses have had to be flexible this
past year from working remotely to
pivoting their business models
for long-term survival and growth
performing arts companies are streaming
stage shows musicals and symphony
concerts online
hey i just did one of those i'm not a
symphony
symphony of [ __ ] and [ __ ] jokes right i
guess
anyways if you're in charge of hiring
for your business these pivots
have made your job even more challenging
especially
if you have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place that you
can always count on to make hiring
faster and easier zip
cruder.com when you post on zip
uh it gets out to over 100 top job
boards on one click
then zip recruit is powerful technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them uh these
people to apply
all right if you're a sub and you want
to get the [ __ ] kicked out of you i'm
sure there's some [ __ ] uh
dominatrix right on there right she'll
be over there stomping on your junk
before you can say zip
credit uh it's no wonder that four out
of five employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day
see for yourself right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free
it's at recruiter.com that's
ziprecruiter.com
b-u-r-r let zip recruiter take finding
qualified candidates off your plate
so you can focus on growing your
business go to super zip recruited dot
com slash burr that zip
hey cleveland the smartest way to hire
all right candid everybody candid
unhappy with your
smile no you don't have to be thousands
of people have used candid the clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
your [ __ ] up teeth and now they and
now all of those people
love their smile okay your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely
by a licensed orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth
movement
he's picturing you going on there he's
on the other screen
all right smile and you do your smile
jesus christ
get out the [ __ ] tupperware for this
one
um your treatment is perfectly
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed author
who's an expert in tooth movement you'll
have the same quality of care you get
from an
from an in-office orthodontist from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
and while other companies use
general dentists uh can candid only
works with orthodontists yeah that's
what you want you want a specialist
you don't want some guy from midas
muffler doing your transmission
uh with candid candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan
is there with you from start to finish
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then
i mean can you put a price on being able
to laugh at a joke
come on you know what's great too is now
that you know during this whole pandemic
you can do this at home nobody even
knows right
even when you go out you're behind your
mask people don't see it it's invisible
anyways but it's even more
uh covert and then one day right
one day you know the pandemic's over
you take your mask off you take your man
bun out of your [ __ ]
out of its scrunchie you do a little
this and a little lat right
sun hits your face and your brand new
shiny [ __ ] white straight teeth and
that broader wouldn't [ __ ] you before
covet is all over you
sitting in your lap the average candid
treatment lasts just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands of dollars
less than traditional braces
um all right call to action become your
best
you start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save 75
on your candid starter kit go to
candidco.com
and use the code bur that's candidco.com
codeburr take advantage of this limited
time offer to save seventy five dollars
on your static kit
candid co charlie oscar dot com all
right
candid co dot com slash bur b-u-r-r code
bur
b-u-r-r ah look who it is it's v-o-me
come on sit down have a little v on me
yeah all right v
ome helps you take control of your
health so you can improve your energy
gut health and boost your immune
immune system feel me vyomi's
award-winning at home
test decode your cellular micro
micro microcondrial jesus i haven't
heard that since i flunk biology
and microbiome health giving you
powerful insulin
insights within with over 30 health
scores
the only gives you vile vio me
violent i always get a violent gives you
a precise whole food nutrition plan
and precision supplements based on your
unique bio
biological needs eliminates the
guesswork optimize your health get more
energy healthy weight improve gut health
better sleep and much more i'm
i want to [ __ ] do this and i keep
saying i'm going to do it and i haven't
done it yet
they figure out your gut man
what's going on down there what foods
are good for you it's perfect
um biome will tell you how specific
foods affect you you may be eating too
much or
not enough of what your body needs
biomes phone application lets you get
these answers on demand
questions about food just check the app
biomes pattern includes mayo clinic
gsk and others and is used by olympic
gold medalists and elite professional
athletes go to vyom.com
and learn how you can get your unique
insights for better health and wellness
use the promo code burr at checkout to
save ten dollars on your first
first purchase and 55 off all
subscription products that's
viom.com promo code burr v-i-o-m-e
dot com fiome.com promo code burr
all right hey here we go here we go look
at that we got we got somebody writing
back
lady listener she writes back
fair enough oh this is this woman that i
trashed last week when i was in a bad
mood i thought i went too hard on her
i thought i went too hard on a lot of
people on my last podcast before the
wolfgang
van halen went i was in a bad mood um
so then immediately when i get in a bad
mood because the way i joke around it
just comes off
a little too like harsh okay
dear billiam burnington this is the lady
who wrote in complaining about your
comedy bits that say all
women are materialistic oh yeah i
remember you and you're like all my
friends are beautiful and pay for all
their own stuff
and i was actually thinking about that
afterwards it's like really
like how good looking does somebody have
to be to be your friend you only hang
around with good looking people you
shallow so-and-so she says well fair
enough
on most of your points well i appreciate
that because i agree with you
when you're talking about guys you know
your women your girlfriends can't find
guys who aren't addicted to porn and uh
you said something else hilarious in
video games
i was like fair enough she said i agree
with you
that it's [ __ ] that holidays only
pressured the man to provide gifts slash
dinner etc
i think the cause should be shared by
both of the people
i think you should both [ __ ] stay
home and you should decide when you want
to celebrate
oh she says if you want to celebrate now
look at me jump in the gun
uh i guess it's different if there's a
big difference between how much they
make
but i haven't experienced that so i
wouldn't know now before i strain myself
patting my own back
i will also admit that you are also
right about women wanting to know what a
man does for a living
um i don't want to speak for all women
but i definitely look for someone
who is at or near my level of domestic
stuff
so it would be nice to not settle too
far no that makes sense it the whole
thing makes sense
okay because first of all when you get
knocked up you're going to be [ __ ]
laid up and you're not going to be able
to work or at least work
especially if you're running your own
business um you're going to need
somebody to step in
so you need to know
that that the man can provide because
that's the deal the guy has to provide
and the broad has to give you a baby
that's basically it
so what at singles bars women should
still be saying so what do you do for a
living
right and then guys should say hey uh do
you have the ability to make a baby
because if you're barren keep it moving
um
anyway i'm sorry uh so fair enough on
everything thanks for roasting me
um on the podcast i haven't laughed that
hard in forever look at that you're a
good [ __ ] i like you all right thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself some lady
see that why can't more people be like
that
why can't they be like that and i was in
a bad mood and she still [ __ ]
thought it was funny so that's good all
right plane or train
all right dear billy it's a choo-choo
train
all right my friends and i were arguing
over whether it'd be better to live on a
train or a plane
the train is safer but constricted to
the tracks the plane can go anywhere
but who wants to be on a plane all day
what country would your train
car house be in if you chose a tr
if you choose train you got to go train
you got to go train because even if you
had the money
to have your own 747 like a double
decker
like take those ones if you when you go
to europe it's like
it's a two-level plane if you like redid
one of those
all right as big as that would be i mean
be bigger than your [ __ ] house and
everything you're still
you're living on a plane breathing that
awful air
that recycled air um i would absolutely
want to if that's that's a no-brainer i
would i would pick a train
um so i'm assuming you're not allowed
are you allowed to get off the train are
you allowed to get off the plane
um if i'm traveling for the rest of my
life i'm i'm taking a train
and i'm just going to make my circle
small as far as
where i will travel to do shows um
all right what country would your train
car house be in
if you chose train america i'm an
american man usa baby
u.s [ __ ] ad stick it right in [ __ ]
nebraska
bored out of my mind no i would be uh i
don't know
i think i would be uh
pacific northwest is beautiful
kind of gives you something to look at
can i get like a glass
like ceiling on the thing so i could
look at some [ __ ]
i don't know i would say uh somewhere
between
seattle and portland oregon i guess
that's a quick one but um you ever see
those people that just sort of fly
around trying to get frequent miles
frequent flyer miles and build them up
and do all that [ __ ] i mean
they act like they're getting over on
the airline and it's like you're not
you're just
you are earning every one of those
[ __ ] miles
um i just can't imagine all the [ __ ]
you're missing out on
the [ __ ] sciatic nerve issues and all
the stuff you're gonna have
you can stretch all you [ __ ] want to
there was like people like flying to
hong kong and the next day coming right
back
and say um from america vermeer
all right gold digging dad hey billy dad
ass
you are a father and i want to know your
opinion on on how
you think this should be handled for
context i am a female in my late 20s
and have an older sister who has the
same concerns
about our dad that your dad's a gold
digger is this your biological father
this feels like one of those [ __ ]
jerry springer things starting off here
you know what i need i need a sip of
water here
um all right let's see what we got here
all right my dad has just gotten engaged
to his soon-to-be third wife let's call
her sally
uh they are around 60 years old and he's
had a bad record
track record when it comes to
relationship i asked him once
what is it that changes after you get
married
everyone always says after you get
married things change so she asked him
what is it that changes after you get
married his answer to this
question was the woman always tries to
control you
they think that they own you after you
get married
uh hey you know that's that's not 100
false uh in his situation
i think the uh in his situation i think
the opposite is true he has admitted to
things here
and there that support that uh like when
he told
my sister that he wouldn't let my mom go
to nursing school
when they were together because he liked
having her under his thumb
his word oh is this one of these [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who doesn't like to be controlled but
then controls other people i don't get
those people
um you would think if you don't like to
con be controlled that you would then
understand that other people don't
either and you would have empathy
because you don't have to put yourself
in their shoes because you feel the same
way they do
strange strange but i will be lying to
you if i didn't say that i knew a lot of
people like that
anyways he said and when he also
said that he told his last serious
girlfriend
that he had erectile dysfunction but
really he just didn't find her
attractive
yeah there you go he has always been
super vain and really he's
really only dates super small women with
big tits
this dude sounds like a guy's guy from
the mid-1970s
he probably still drinks beer with a
pull tab um
so anyways he he meets he met sally
several years ago and they dated for a
short time before he broke up with her
he told her that it was because he was
scared of falling in love with her
after a year after about a about a year
ago sorry he was talking to my sister
about how we started talking to her
again
and that if he married sally he would be
set for life because she has money
yeah he this is the problem with this
guy is he he goes
he gets into relationships for wrong
reasons
for the wrong reasons money tits those
are all
dumb reasons to marry somebody you know
those are good reasons
to [ __ ] around and have a fling she's
got big tits those will be fun all right
great you know what i mean
i mean i don't i don't like mooching off
people though i draw the line on money
now anyway they began dating he began
dating her a few months ago a few months
later sorry
uh they are engaged and he is chomping
at the bit to get the marriage
over and done with good i'm glad he's
chomping at the [ __ ] she'll probably
sense that and call it off hopefully my
question is should i bring this up with
him and see if he really is in love with
her
should i try and contact her and feel
out how things are going with them
i have never even spoken to this woman
should i just say
[ __ ] it if she's dumb enough to get
herself into this situation
then it's on her i disagree with they
always say that well you're the one who
married her
it's like if somebody's lying to you
and saying that they love you
you know how are you supposed to know uh
anyway she has kids
and would hope that if they thought it
was fishy they would talk to her
about their concerns if it were my mom i
would be all over her telling her
wait until she really knows what she's
getting into
yeah but if you were her daughter you
know the guy that she was marrying
wouldn't come up to you and say hey you
know i'm trying to marry your mother so
i can be set financially you know
huh you're with me i'm taking part of
your inheritance there little sweetheart
right
uh should i insert myself into the
situation or should i leave it be
i've only been close with my dad for a
few years when i was a teenager and
since then it's just been a distance
relationship i would really love some
advice from you
and the lovely nia if she is available
i'm a huge fan and wish you and your
wonderful family the best of luck
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself uh i would
say it all depends on what sort of
relationship you want to have with your
dad
because he'll get [ __ ] he will be
[ __ ] livid
if he finds out that you [ __ ] this
thing up
um but it is kind of weird to just
stand back and it's just like if if he's
gonna take her for money
you know what about those kids and [ __ ]
so
i don't know what to tell you here
um you've never talked to her
they're in their 60s
but even then some people that just not
good at reading people and if he's just
telling her all of this [ __ ]
but he said he didn't he i don't know
your dad's a weird dude he doesn't
really say what he's really thinking
he's like you know he got erectile
dysfunction and then goes like i you
know i don't find you attractive
so that wasn't really what was going on
and then he said he broke up with her
because he was afraid he was going to
fall in love with her
so maybe he's a there's there's a world
where he can be afraid to tell you how
much he loves her in mr when they were
broken up
so he's just acting like it's about
money or he really is like that so you
have to figure that out
considering this guy doesn't seem to be
the most honest dude out there
and then you have to kind of i mean
there's
there's no one of my favorite
expressions
no good deed goes unpunished all right
um oh speaking of which thank you to
everybody who watched the patrice
o'neill documentary
uh killing is easy if you want to see
the full unedited edit they had to take
14 minutes out
uh it's on comedycentral.com it's on
their their uh
their website and i was very i was
thrilled with the feedback
that i got from fans of his and
especially from other comics
um and i'm telling you it was all mike
bonfiglio
is just a friggin genius
um i feel like uh
you know people were giving me too much
credit all i did was he just called me
up and was saying
hey do you have this con this comedian
can you i'd like to get him in can you
do that that's all i did like he
i didn't sit in the edit room he did he
he put mike bonfiglio did the thing
all right there we go okay uh boyfriend
says i'm getting
cankles um
wait did i finish with that yeah so
that's what i would do and i would just
you know you know there's ways to do it
anonymously
you know i don't know i don't know
personally i would probably just stay
out of it
uh that's one of those things it's just
one of those [ __ ] things if you don't
know the other person
how do you [ __ ] bridge that gap and
then the other person you're related to
like how do you call somebody up say hey
just let you know my dad's kind of a
selfish [ __ ] and he said uh
if he gets with you he'll be financially
all set i mean you know what you prob
maybe you
can do it anonymously do it anonymously
and then just deny it and just see what
the [ __ ] happens that's
that's the closest thing you could do
but i wouldn't insert maybe there's a
way to do it that way i don't know
all right boyfriend says i'm getting
cankles
dear billy blue blue balls uh my
boyfriend and i have been dating for two
years when we met we were both
college athletes he is still very
athletic and trim
after 15 years in sports i've grown
tired of fitness
and have stopped working out as a result
i've gained some weight i've lost my abs
and i have some pudgy baby fat
all around my body now um
all right first thing i think with a lot
of athletes because you train so hard
and all of that [ __ ] like you just get
burned out
um i would suggest finding a new way to
train
because one of the worst things you can
do is let your body go it
affects i mean you're just putting on
your [ __ ] socks become everything
just becomes more difficult you lose
energy you get depressed you die sooner
um staying active is extremely important
and
you know if you did a bunch of running
and [ __ ] when you were
a younger athlete i just don't run do
something else
get into like cooking in nutritious ways
i would do [ __ ] like that but please
don't
don't stop don't let yourself go because
there's a tipping point you can't get it
back um anyway yesterday he pointed out
that i'm developing cankles
google if you need to i don't um he said
most of my weight is going to my legs
he said he noticed them when we
initially started dating
but they are very noticeable now he
prefers women with toned
muscle muscular legs and said it's
something
that secretly bothers him i admit it
even if i'm trim
and in shape my legs still have baby fat
even around the ankles it's kind of
strange i think it's genetic
yeah i mean you're really talking about
something you can't help here he goes
between the cankles and the fact that
i'm not working out not anymore
i'm worried he's going to break up with
me unless i start hitting the gym
he's a fitness nut so i can see why he
wants to be with an athletic girl
but i also feel like he's being kind of
sh
of shallow and an [ __ ] what do you
think i'm searching
surgery to reduce my cankles
um p.s i think you're sexy with the
shaved head with that
said go [ __ ] yourself now wait a minute
i think you're already looking you're
already
mentally set up kid um all right i would
say this
you're you're right you're both kind of
right here
you're right that he's being a shallow
[ __ ]
all right and the fact that what he said
to you makes you research
surgery to reduce your cancer is like
that's like heartbreaking you can't do
that to somebody
can't do that to anybody okay so
first of all don't do that all right
but secondly in his shallow [ __ ] way
he's also bringing up
a really important thing which is you
can't let yourself go
you can't do it out of respect for
yourself
and the person that you're with you have
to be making a [ __ ] effort
to stay in shape okay and when you're
with somebody and they're getting out of
shape
it's really difficult to tell them that
so what you have to do
is you know try to work out with them
and stuff like that
and and uh i would just say to the guy
just be like look you know what you said
you were kind of being
you know i understand you know there's a
point there but the way you did it
really hurt me and i'm literally on the
internet like searching
surgery to reduce my my [ __ ]
leg fat or whatever um
you know and then and then just see
where it goes from there if you want to
push it further
we can be like all right so what if i
put another 15 pounds on you're just
gonna break up with me does that mean
like you know so
because if that's the case you don't
really love me and then what the [ __ ] am
i doing here
um so there's sort of the little
conversation
and and then sort of the bigger thing
that this brings up
um so i wouldn't come at them in an
angry way but let's just have an honest
conversation here
all right just have an honest
conversation okay i'm going to tell you
what
what you said to me how it made me feel
i am going to start working out
but it also made me feel like if i got
to a certain way
that you would break up with me is is
that how you are
and i'm not going to get mad but just
let me know if that's how you are
and then if he says okay that is how i
am all right then i would just make an
assessment if like
he just liked you because you had abs um
i don't know
there's a lot there's a lot there and
there's only an email and i don't know
anybody involved but like don't don't
[ __ ] get surgery because
your boyfriend said something stupid all
right
okay there we go but don't give up on
yourself don't give up on us baby
don't give up on yourself you don't
don't you're burned out from working out
you can still go for walks in the in
um eating healthy is delicious and you
feel amazing
afterwards so you just gotta uh
you know do that [ __ ] okay
anyway girlfriend wears makeup at work
to attract attention
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy let's get
into this one here
all right dear uh cheers mr burrito
oh by the way to all my mexican
listeners the other night when i went to
the taco truck i got a torta and i got i
got some tacos
okay i didn't have the gringo white boy
order of the burrito although i gotta
tell you it was tough to lay off because
i am a white boy gringo
[ __ ] burrito eating son of a [ __ ] i
am
how do you say in spanish you burrito
eating son of a [ __ ]
please somebody
i want to be yo yo soy uh burrito eating
son of a [ __ ]
all right um cheers mr burrito uh love
the podcasts and all that good stuff
i'll cut right to the chase since i know
how hard it is for you to read out loud
thank you i appreciate
you have empathy i like you all right
basically
my girlfriend my lady works at the local
pizza shop
and dolls herself up in order to get
more tips from customers hey you know
that's the hustle i get that
she's a very beautiful girl and we've
been dating for a little over two years
i love her to death
we've talked about marriage we agree on
the important things and all that [ __ ]
blah blah blah
we're both in our early 20s and go to
university together and thank god she's
not one of those people
who's been brainwashed by the university
and can think for herself
nice parenthesis so she's special i
think
i think you're right anyway she knows if
she puts on makeup and
makes herself look cute she can attract
more trips from customers
tips from customers it'd be one thing if
she was poor and needed the money but
her parents have loads of it
and made a good amount at her uh
big shot accounting job but what but her
parents have loads of it and made a good
amount
at her big shot accounting job over the
summer
oh she made money
she's 100 she 100 does not need it
and even quit a shift because she was
too bored
i feel like she is doing it for the
attention
and has even said to me that it makes
her feel good about herself
at first i thought this might be a huge
issue
at the same time her friends have become
big losers since they all got into
relationships
and her school work has gotten pretty
easy since we're both seniors
basically she's she is bored and i am
unable to be 100 attentive to her since
i'm still kind of busy and also my
friends are not lame
jesus christ you sound like a young guy
i get this all right initially
i initially told her she can't wear
makeup because she's
preying on lonely guys to give her extra
money
but then second guessed myself and now i
let her wear it
anyway not sure what to do here i feel
like i'm being
ridiculous by putting my foot down since
after all
it is mostly harmless but also it still
bothers me i'd appreciate
any advice you have all right well the
biggest thing you said there is you owed
up to the fact
that it bothers you okay
so there's ways to say that to somebody
by not saying i forbid you to wear
makeup to work
because like first let's be honest here
it bothers you
you you love her and you don't want to
lose her that's
that is the core of it and and and if
we're going to be totally honest you
could give a [ __ ] about those lonely
guys sitting there
you don't care about them you care about
you you care about your
relationship okay so um i think you have
a beautiful motivated person here who
made a bunch of money
even said her big shot accounting job
that makes me feel like you have issues
about that too
so i think what you need to do is get a
little more confidence here
get a little more swagger she's with you
she loves you she's
you guys are all on the same page about
everything and
uh you know you need to listen to a
little 38 special here hold on
loosely but don't let go right you gotta
you get you can't do this okay if she
likes going there
i mean part of it could also be it makes
her feel good
to be out working earning money rather
than sitting around on her ass
and um he also took a pot shot at her
friends
which i get you know your age and [ __ ]
is just like you know
they probably want to watch real
housewives and stuff and you're kind of
like you know i want to go do this other
[ __ ]
um you know i would do i would uh try to
dial down my
insecurity try to figure out
why you feel that way you know if you
got a little bit of money go go talk to
a therapist
or maybe just talk to her just just sit
down with her and just say listen you
know it bothers me that it bothers me
that you wear makeup but i'm too
insecure
to i'm telling you women love that [ __ ]
they [ __ ] love that [ __ ] it's open
communication they get it right and then
also in a way
she's like oh my god oh my god you love
me that much right
as opposed to being like hey listen lady
you [ __ ] put that clown [ __ ] on your
face again we're gonna have [ __ ]
problems stay over make me a [ __ ]
yeah stake them you know you can't come
at him that way
you'll drive him away so i think it was
really big of you by the end that you
said it still bothers you when you
you know you think you're being a little
like ridiculous so
um you know
you you can't keep somebody by trying
well i guess you can if you get like a
weak person you could just totally
dominate them and not let him go outside
anymore
all right i don't know what i'm talking
about anymore yeah i would i would i
would ease up on the reins
and i this this is a you issue this
isn't a her
issue um and i think that you can work
it out if you sit down and you talk to
her and just
tell her that you feel ridiculous and
whatever embarrassed that you
said what you said but it came from a
place that not wanted to lose you and
just
just dude just tell them what you're
thinking i know it's weird at your age
but i'm telling you it actually [ __ ]
works all right there you go
okay so that is the podcast i'm gonna
sit down and watch the bruins versus the
[ __ ] flyers
up there in lake tahoe just outside of
reno one of my favorite [ __ ] cities
to do stand up in i love that place
bizarre guitar and gun shop is one of
the coolest [ __ ] strip mall things
i've ever been to
to in my life um
who knows well that's it all right oh
billy virtual comic
and podcaster here is signing off you
guys have a great couple of days go [ __ ]
yourself go bruins go
celtics go [ __ ] yourselves and i will
check in on you
on thursday